zäsur in großbritannien der tod von
elizabeth der zweite notiert vielleicht
eine zeitenwende die monarchie muss
sichtbar sein das war immer ihr motto
nun muss charles der dritte nach 70
jahren probezeit liefern ohne die queen
was wird aus dem vereinigten königreich
phoenix runde
es sind bilder für die ewigkeit der sarg
von elizabeth der zweite in westminster
hall ein besonderer abschied von einer
jahrhundertfigur und damit willkommen
meine damen und herren zur phoenix runde
ich darf ihnen unsere gäste vorstellen
wir begrüßen in london thomas kielinger
er beobachtet seit jahrzehnten das
britische königshaus er ist queen
biograf und autor für die welt für die
ja auch lange korrespondent war größe
nach london herr kieninger ich darf
herzlich hier in dieser runde begrüßen
juni patterson erst britischer
journalist mit sitz in berlin er
schreibt seit vielen jahren für den
independent und für den daily telegraph
schön dass sie da sind toni patterson zu
meiner linken haben wir thomas matussek
er diente als deutscher botschafter in
großbritannien zwischen 2002 und 2006
weitere veränderungen waren zum beispiel
bei den vereinten nationen un in indien
und das ist jetzt der königswinter
konferenz vor herzlich willkommen und
besonders herzlich willkommen noch
anwender linie von bredow die zu uns
gekommen ist dieses leiterin des
berliner büros vom economist einer sehr
etablierten wirtschaftsmagazine in
großbritannien auch mit großer tradition
18 43 glaube ich das erste mal
erschienen verheiratet mit einem briten
und lange in london gelebt schön dass
sie alle da sind meine damen und herren
beginnen wollen wir in london weil uns
interessiert wie die aktuellen eindrücke
sind killinger menschen warten viele
stunden über eine sehr lange strecke
kilometer lang um abschied zu nehmen von
der queen wie ist die atmosphäre wie ist
die stimmung wie fühlt die britische
nation in diesen tagen
man kann es sich anders bezeichnet als
ergreifend schlagen sich die
physiognomie der menschen an die dort
kommen und an dem catterfeld vorbeigehen
es ist an dem multikulturelle
gesellschaft eine mini uno werden weil
sie die die mischung der bevölkerung
dieses landes repräsentiert für das gros
im elisabeth sehr viel getan hat dass
england in ihrer zeit immer stärker
obwohl die kulturell sozusagen sich
auszeichnet sie hat ja sehr am konkurs
gegangen
auf das kommen was geschworen und hat
sehr viel dafür getan dass england
selber in dem bereich in dem mehr und
mehr afrikanische staaten im kongo es
traten seinerseits multikulturellen
wurde ich glaube das wird man später mal
als eine ihrer großen leistungen
anerkennen und das sieht man in den
gesichtern diese menschen die dort
vorbei ziehen teilweise sich verbeugen
teilweise der hofknicks anbringen sich
bekreuzigen ist eine ergreifende wie
soll ich sagen repräsentanz der
nationalen stimmung die familie kommt
hier einmal zusammen und was das ganze
auch mit converse und der historischen
würdigung bedeutet da kommen wir in der
sendung gleich zurück vielen dank für
dieses andré frau von bredow der
spectator auch eine sehr etablierte
britische zeitschrift hat mal über sie
geschrieben sie sei eine traditionelle
rebellin was war die queen für sie und
ihre familie familie es gibt ja auch
durchaus eine persönliche ebene also die
war einfach ein symbol ein symbol für
die krone ein symbol für großbritannien
und die sie war so über sie stand über
allen und sie hat das land auch sehr
zusammengehalten und das ist etwas
glaube ich dafür wurde sie so besonders
respektiert und auch gemocht weil sie
eben diese rolle als junger fahrer hatte
als jemand der der alle vereinte und das
sind ja gerade in der zeit ist den
letzten jahren aber großbritannien sehr
gespalten wegen rexit und die queen hat
das dann irgendwie noch zusammengehalten
jeweils farbe eines blumenstraußes oder
die farbe einer eines outfits
danke ihnen herr matussek sie hatten das
privileg durch ihre funktion in der
eigenschaft als deutscher botschafter
die queen persönlich zu treffen
warum sind wir so fasziniert von dieser
frau sie waren es möglicherweise auch ja
ich war es auch die königin hatte so
etwas wie eine aura ja das hat nicht
jeder nicht jeder politiker nicht jeder
bürger also zum beispiel leute die sie
am fernsehen sehen haben das gefühl sie
spricht weg zu ihnen
wenn sie leute in einem großen raum
haben sagten mir anschließend die hat
mich die ganze zeit angeguckt also das
war diese aura und diese stille würde
das war ihre public persona ihre
öffentliche personen im persönlichen
gespräch und ich hatte das große glück
und die ehre einige male mit ihr
unter vier augen zusammen zusammen ist
sie von einer ausserordentlichen
offenen herzlichkeit sie lacht sehr
gerne
sie führt das also man führt mit der
königin nicht das gespräch sie sollen
sie führt es mit einem sie führt einen
so durch die themen durch sie ist
blendend vorbereitet sie versteht mehr
von politik würde ich sagen als viele
von uns die wir 40 jahren diplomaten
warnen
und sie ist
man hat nach dem gespräch das gefühl
dass sie einen wirklich auch als mensch
nahe gekommen ist
und natürlich wenn jemand 16
premierminister erlebt dort und
wöchentliche audienzen mit ihnen
abgehalten hat kann man davon ausgehen
dass ganz viel auch dann da an expertise
zusammen gekommen ist und selbst turtle
ihr erster premier war sofort begeistert
vielen dank für diesen ersten moment wir
knüpfen gleich noch einmal an auch an
der leistung von ihr johnny pedersen
armen die queen hat viele bewegt
durchaus auch die skeptiker der
monarchie es kann nicht jeder ein fan
sein das ist durchaus klar auch in
diesem raum dass man vielleicht auch ein
bisschen mehr republikaner ist
eigentlich jetzt mal im wasser lockt
aber ihr tod markiert einen tiefen
einschnitt warum ist das so dass
sozusagen die fans aber eben auch die
anderen irgendwie empfinden jetzt ist
jemand nicht mehr da ich denke wenn ich
von mir selber sprecher in meiner
familie war die queen überhaupt kein
thema wir haben nie über sie geredet
und weil man ganzen freunde in
großbritannien rechnen auch nicht über
die queen aber die war die ganze zeit da
und wenn so jemand einfach verschwindet
fühlt man natürlich das was was gegangen
ist und das kann man nicht wieder
wiederholen natürlich etwas fehlt auch
bei auch bei den leuten die nicht
grösser fans von von der queen sind aber
ich persönlich habe ein gefühl von
gewisse erleichterung ich denke es war
schon zeit dass sie geht ich wäre
zufrieden gewesen wenn sie sagen wir vor
20 jahren abgedankt hätte und charles
zumindest eine chance gegeben hätte weil
sie eine erwartung anschauen es haben
alle darüber was diese erwartung
ausmacht wer gleich noch in der sendung
zurück vielen dank auch für diesen
einstieg wenn wir sozusagen jetzt
gemeinsam noch einmal schauen auf dieses
kapitel auf diese 70 jahre regentschaft
und der kinder ich schaue noch mal in
ihre richtung da ist ja dann in 70
jahren durchaus raum für licht und
schatten sag ich jetzt mal wo war schon
auf dieser regentschaft
schatten lag interessante weise in ihre
beziehungen zu ihren eigenen kindern sie
ist eine frau die seine generation in
der masse einmischte in die in die
eigenen nach beruht sozusagen und immer
davon ausging dass die probleme die in
den nachwachsenden generationen stehen
sich von selber legen die berühmte stiff
upper lip habe ihre generation und auch
wenn philip ihren mann ausgezeichnet das
hat sich dann schlecht erwiesen als
mittelbar an und heute harry und wecken
jungen menschen herankommen die durchaus
mit ihren krisen auch ihre mentalen
problemen ernst genommen werden wollen
die queen hat sich nie eingemischt das
war ihre grundsätzliche überzeugung
einmal hat sie einen brief an charles
und diana geschrieben im dezember 1995
als in ried dass dieser streit aufhören
muss sie mögen sich bitte beide scheiden
lassen sonst hat sie sich zurückgehalten
und ich glaube diese diese defizite
sozusagen eine generation wie man
miteinander umgeht haben sie und das
familienleben teilweise lastet das wird
unter charles und auf seinen sohn anders
sein die gehören zu einer anderen welt
eine kultur welt in dem uns stärker über
persönliche persönliche probleme auch
sprechen ja über diese anforderung
können wir gleich noch sprechen wir
müssen einen anderen punkt streifen das
ist jetzt komme ich nochmal sony
patterson das ist das stichwort
kolonialismus
das ist das große schweigen der queen
gewesen eine keine offizielle
entschuldigung auch keine
wiedergutmachung es gibt ja diese
forderungen ist das jetzt aufgabe der
folgenden generationen ich denke schon
nicht ich denke king chance der dritte
das ist eine unmittelbare notwendigkeit
dass da was macht weil man denkt einfach
zurück als die queen queen würde 52
anfang der 50er jahre war es ihnen die
bekam die nachricht in kenia und gerade
in kenia haben die briten also diese mau
mau rebellion total ist nie die 52 war
und es gibt auch sachen den in indien
zum beispiel dieses massaker von
amritsar 19 anfang des 19 jahrhunderts
tausende leute niedergeschossen wurden
und sie hat die sich dafür entschuldigt
richtig sie hat
kommentiert aber nicht richtig
entschuldigt und ich denke die viele
leute in den kolonien ehemaligen
kolonien in den ländern in den
commonwealth ländern wo die königin ein
kind aus der dritte jetzt monarchist die
wollen eine entschuldigung hören
da ist also einiges zu tun ganz generell
muss man ja sagen herr matussek
sie hat keine politische macht gehabt
das hat kein monarch trotzdem gibt es
die erwartung dass die
gesellschaftlichen prozesse mit
betrieben werden inwieweit hat sie dem
land gut getan an welcher stelle also
ich würde sagen wenn man es richtig
versteht hat sich schon eine politische
macht denn sie ist der muss man sagen
der der punkt die fahne um die sich die
nation auch das kommendes versammelt und
sie gibt ihm halt durch ihr dasein und
dadurch dass sie mit einer großen würde
diese einheit
symbolisiert
automatisch komme ich jetzt auf eine
antwort was ich aus meiner zeit in
indien kenne das ja
wäre der kuh der herrscher sitzt da und
macht gar nichts die menschen kommen und
schauen ihnen nur an und dieses
anschauen durch dieses anschauen geht
etwas an nennen wir es mal vibrationen
etwas über und der königin erinnert sie
mich auch so ein bisschen an den gashahn
kein mensch erwartet von ihr dass sie
sich in die tagespolitik einschaltet
aber sie ist in den richtigen moment den
richtigen zeiten da und es gab ja
durchaus moment sind ihre 70 jahren
regentschaft wo sie auch gegen den rat
der premierminister in farbe bekannt hat
das war zum beispiel die kommune world
konferenz damals in afrika wo sie hin
gefahren ist messenger war dagegen weil
sie sagt das sind alles diese
freiheitskämpfer usw wohin soll das
führen und sie hat diesen gipfel zu
einem erfolg gemacht und david o der
frühere außenminister hat man von ihr
gesagt in rassenfragen ist die völlig
farbenblind und das sieht man auch an
ihrer großen beliebtheit selbst in einem
land wie indien wo ich nun sieben jahre
meines lebens verbracht habe und die
wahrhaftig sie spielten auf andere zu an
behaftet eine leidvolle geschichte haben
war sie immer eigentlich auch eine
person mit der man gerne da schauen
hatte
wenn ich wenn ja gerne hätte ich es
nicht eingehalten da die pattinson hat
durchaus recht dieses land
großbritannien hat einen großen bedarf
an vergangenheitsbewältigung und den
kolonialismus gehört natürlich dazu man
muss dabei unterscheiden wer dafür
verantwortlich ist dieses zu
artikulieren dies könnte könig kann es
glaube ich nicht kraft seine
neutralitätspflicht er ist nicht dafür
da in die aktuellen debatten
einzuschreiten aber die wissenschaft die
diskussion in großbritannien muss sich
natürlich damit auseinandersetzen dabei
darf man auch nicht vergessen dass diese
staaten werden viele von ihnen unter den
britischen kolonialismus gelitten haben
ja eigentlich überraschender weise immer
sofort zu partie unabhängig wurden ins
kommen weils eintraten wenn es denn so
schlecht gegangen wäre unter den
brutalen britischen kolonialismus würde
man annehmen dass sie einen großen
abstand zu großbritannien gewonnen haben
aber es stimmte nicht sie sind geblieben
in einer vereinigung mit großbritannien
als symbolischen kopf das ist schon sehr
interessant das aufarbeiten der begangen
hat ist wichtig die auch so wichtig ist
kann nicht von königshaus stattfinden
das muss auf den verschiedenen ebenen
der gesellschaft passieren gut das
nehmen wir ergänzend auf jeden fall hier
mit rein und ich würde gerne frau von
bredow an verschiedenen produkten muss
ein monarch mehr oder weniger auch dinge
hinnehmen die vielleicht nicht in seinem
sinne sind praxis würde eine frage sein
und sie schreiben für eine wirtschaft
für ein wirtschaftsmagazin für den
economist das ist der eine punkt an
andere punkt war schottland was ja auch
sozusagen am ende des tages nicht nur
eine politische sondern eine ökonomische
frage ist glaube ich überliefert dass
sie sehr gespannt auf dieses referendum
20 geschaut hat und sich von dem
premierminister der hat das dann später
verbreitet das übermitteln lassen oder
gesagt jetzt geschnürt wie ein kätzchen
als sie gehört hat dass es gescheitert
ist also wo ist der spielraum dann auch
für sie gewesen also der spielraum ist
von der verfassung nicht sehr groß oder
von der der ist ja eine ungeschriebene
verfassung aber sie hat sie hat sie auch
wirklich daran gehalten eigentlich
nichts man wusste nicht so sie hat sich
nicht geäußert zu der tagesaktualität
und zb man nimmt man weiß ich also ich
glaube die praxis der denken sie hätte
es unterstützt und die die männer denken
sie hätten sie unterstützt das ist
natürlich auch eine große begabung dass
in beiden so zu vermitteln also da war
sie schon sehr sehr vorsichtig und das
ist bei charles an der es nicht bei
charles der hat sie immer seit jahren
schon seine meinung geäußert er war an
für sich sehr früh auf dem umweltthema
und architektur und diese sachen die
interessieren aber der der hat sich da
sehr viel stärker schon in die bresche
geworfen und das wird sich glaub ich
auch weiterhin ändern das heißt er wird
an einem könig mit meinungen seien und
sie hat sich doch immer sehr
zurückgehalten sicher hat sich die
meinung seine kluge und sehr wohl
informierte frau wie die hamatech sagt
er aber sie hat sie sah ihre rolle als
ihre pflicht sich eben überall zu stehen
und das ist laden zu vereinen und eben
sich nicht äußern
im moment beginnen die historiker so
langsam auch zu schauen die man diese
regentschaft einordnen kann es fällt
jetzt immer stärker herr killinger hat
es auch in seinem essay erwähnt aber ich
beginne jetzt mal durch matussek der
begriff vom zweiten elisabeth amischen
zeitalter man fragt dann immer sozusagen
das individuum und die institution ist
das jetzt zu früh es so zu benennen oder
wird sie dem schon gerecht
die frage ist was zu früh ich glaube man
sollte bei der endgültigen einordnung
schon noch ein bisschen warten aber eins
ist klar erstens sie saß länger auf dem
thron als jeder ihrer vorgänger das ist
schon was und in der zeit hat natürlich
großbritannien unerhörte ups and downs
erlebt nicht denken sie an den verlust
des der welt machtstellung es mal so zu
nennen denken sie an die großen
wirtschaftskrisen der 70er jahre
wechselt ist schon genannt worden und
was das gekommen weil es angeht da würde
ich gerne zu tom schilling ob das sagen
du hast natürlich vollkommen recht
allerdings das bröckelt jetzt ja wenn
man die linken die jüngste besuchs
diplomatie um es mal so zu nennen der
world sich anschaut also diese harmonie
des commonwealth die wirtschaft nicht in
der form aber was die historische
einordnung angeht da durch die
zurückgehen auf wie was jemand im 16
jahrhundert mal geschrieben hat er
gesagt der monarch a2 körper er hat den
physischen körper der jetzt gestorben
ist aber er hat auch den körper der das
land das reich die geschichte verkörpert
und ich glaube dieser körper wird
weiterleben und der muss fortgetragen
werden von charts dem dritten aber jetzt
bevor wir zu ihm übergehen er war immer
noch ein bisschen die würdigung
versuchen die wahrscheinlich bei toni
patterson etwas weniger gnädig ausfallen
wird und dieses zweite elisabethanische
zeitalter kann ja auch nur funktionieren
wenn sie und das war ja das erklärte
ziel die regentschaft von von queen
victoria auf jeden fall überrundet mit
ihren 63 jahren die viktoria auf dem
thron saß dann also jetzt diese 70 jahre
aber wenn man fragt was bleibt was wäre
das aus ihrer perspektive
was bleibt sie hat einen großbritannien
hinterlassen die eigentlich in einer
krise steckt wenn man daran denkt so
aber dafür ist sie verantwortlich oder
die qualität an das ist die politik
natürlich aber sie hat eigentlich großes
geleistet
wenn man denkt also versöhnung mit
deutschland besuch in deutschland 1965
und besucher in irland wo sie ihre
gesprochen hat und die fesseln aber
petra grüne farbe diese gesten waren
sehr sehr viel wert in der auf der
internationalen arena in großbritannien
selber ist für mich ist sie die
verkörperung von stiff upper lip also
den steifen oberlippe und
das war das motto und ich denke die
briten seit
prinzessin diana zumindest etwas anderes
erwarten und die erwarten dass jetzt mit
könig aus den dritten und er fängt an
mit das zu zeigen wir wollen jetzt
sozusagen noch thomas kielinger noch in
dieser runde der was bleibt von
elisabeth da auf jeden fall noch mal
rein bringen also das elisabethanische
zeitalter der begriff ist gefallen sie
haben verwendet was bleibt von dieser
regentschaft was kann man jetzt schon
sagen
ich glaube es bleibt die anhänglichkeit
der briten um diese partitur ihre
verfasstheit so wie ich das königtum mir
ne ne über diese 70 jahre von enormen
wandel tumult harisch manchmal hat es
sie dennoch geschafft die anhängigkeit
der briten zu der form ihre verfasst
zeit und zur ausstrahlung in der welt
nicht anzutasten gegenteil auch nach 70
jahren ist die mehrheit der briten
überzeugt dass sie von dieser
institution nicht lassen wollen ich
finde das ist eine ganz bemerkenswerte
leistung dass sie die partitur wie ich
es nenne die die die zugehörigkeit zum
zum antiken
institutionen der monarchie dass die
intakt geblieben ist das ist enorm man
kann es gar nicht unterschätzen weil die
welt doch so
getrieben ist von unruhen von tumulten
hat es diese figur geschafft ihrem lande
weiter die gründe zu liefern warum sie
unter der monarchie fortgesetzt leben
wollen ich finde das ist sozusagen ganz
bemerkenswerte leistung ihrer 70 jahre
team bleibt
genau mit dem zu aber man muss schon
sagen also wenn man sich jetzt die
umfragen an schatz sind 62 prozent der
briten unterstützen die monarchie und
der rest in different oder dagegen ja
also es hat also zwei drittel ist sehr
viel aber ich glaube diese zustimmung
ist auch zerbrechlich also es ist hängt
jetzt schon sehr viel von charles ab wie
er mit dieser fantastischen
lebensleistung wie herr killinger sagte
sie hat das mit unglaublicher würde und
auch mit einem pflichtbewusstsein ich
mein leben wirklich ihrer pflicht
gegeben gemacht aber das hängt jetzt vom
zab das weiterzuführen nicht und ob er
das mit seiner anderen art er zeigt der
emotion er hat meinungen nicht ob das
gehen wird nicht das ist nicht ich
glaube nicht dass man denken kann die
monarchie wird jetzt für die nächsten 50
jahre sich am sattel sein also das kann
auch sehr schnell kippen das hat man
gesehen bei dem tod von der prinz ist ja
nicht wie schnell die stimmung gibt eine
katze lothar die hat sie dort ganz am
ende gestoppt bei einem sieg nicht nur
von schwarz ab und ich glaube die zeit
hat sich auch so stark geändert dass
sich da ein petersen zustimmen würde
wenn heute noch mal 19 53 wäre und sie
holz and roll verdi werden situation
anders ich glaube es gibt eine in diesen
21ten jahrhunderts
säkulare große bewegungen die
das ist das muss ich sehr vorsichtig
sein wo ich auch der meinung bin für die
die monarchie nicht unbedingt die
geeignete staatsform ist aber das ist
etwas was die briten entscheiden müssen
damit man mich nicht falsch versteht
aber ich glaube
jede zeit hat auch ihr ablaufdatum und
ich glaube in der in der in der
monarchie selbst wenn charles das
fantastisch machen sollte und william
sie werden ist in vieler beziehung
schwerer haben die institution der
monarchie in diese neue zeit darüber zu
holen in der tat man muss sozusagen auch
zu ihrer ehrenrettung noch zugestehen
dass er bereits 2002 in reden auch
stellung genommen hat zum wandel den man
sich nicht verschließen soll und das
monarchie nur überlebensfähig ist wenn
sie volksnah ist aber gleichzeitig auch
majestätisch der größte charles fan am
tisch ist toni patterson sie haben
70 jahre trainer und jetzt ist er dran
wir was dürfen wir von ihm erwarten ich
denke einen ganz anderen stil und er
fängt anders zu zeigen war der gefühle
zeigt und das hat chris muss nicht
gemacht wirklich
erst dafür kritisiert worden schon jetzt
und besonders in amerika
erstaunlicherweise aber er macht das er
ist mehr ein mensch ich meine ist vor
kurzem gezeigt wurde dass er sich
aufregt
wahlalters der landes- und der war sauer
und aber das ist so ein mensch das ist
nicht eine puppe
das königshaus
ich denke er hat natürlich eine meinung
er hat er im interview vor einiger zeit
gesagt also wenn sie könig sind werden
sie auch eine meinung haben wie heute
und er hat gesagt für an nord hat typ
ist also so doof bin ich nicht die große
frage ist inwiefern die rolle des königs
also verwirklichen kann und seine
meinung durchsetzen ohne dazustehen
alles besser wissen besseren
klimaschutz oder sowas ich denke dass
wird er nur tun können wenn er mit
seinen unterredungen mit politiker das
sagt aber dass er ein deckel drauf hätte
hält und nicht stellt überall rumlaufen
sagt aber auch super gefährlich weil man
ja weiß dass hintergrundgespräche
heutzutage meist nicht mehr im
hintergrund bleiben aber thomas
kielinger um daran zu knüpfen an das was
toni patterson sagt in diesen
jahrzehnten des wortes standes wenn es
mal so formulieren darf hat ja es war
überhaupt nicht untätig galt als das
fleißigste mitglied der königsfamilie
und er hat auch mit prince's trust er
hat ja auch wirklich sehr viele dinge
etabliert ich glaube da sind tausende
mitarbeiter beschäftigt hat aber jetzt
auch gesagt das muss ich jetzt weiter
geben also wie viel spielraum hat er
jetzt und wie geht das sozusagen weiter
mit dem was bisher seine lieblingsthemen
bahn
hat den großen vorteil dass diese
lieblingsthemen von könig charles den
dritten inzwischen das welt gespräch
nummer eins ist nämlich die bewahrung
der schöpfung der umgang mit den
ressourcen die nachhaltigkeit der
klimaschutz der klimawandel das hat er
im gefolge seines vaters prinz philip
war ähnlich eingestellt sehr früh
entdeckt und auf seine fahnen
geschrieben er muss in der hinsicht gar
nicht dazu denn sondern wir stellen fest
dass er eigentlich auf der höhe der
gegenwärtigen diskussion ist er muss
also nicht unnötig viel druck ausüben
überhaupt gar keinen druck das kann
endlich darf er nicht er kann zu bilden
freundlich begleiten wie die politik
dies grüne thema sozusagen in seinem
sinne weiter vorantreibt und das ist für
ihn ein vorteil ist von vornherein
akzeptabel mit seinem hauptthema das
heute von der gesellschaft insgesamt
mitgetragen wird
[Musik]
nein ich wollte einfach noch folgendes
sagen das ist alles richtig nur
die königliche familie oder die firma
wie prinz philip sie genannt hat da
hatte jeder an bestimmten part zu
spielen die königin war sozusagen das
zentrum des sonnensystems und in diesen
in diesem kosmos hatte tauss eine ganz
bestimmte rolle die aber eine andere
rolle waren als selber zentrum zu sein
und so sympathisch das ist wenn man sich
menschlich zeigt mit all seinen
schwächen
es ist eine gefahren geneigte tätigkeit
wenn sie in saint wenn sie im zentrum
sind und ich glaube ich glaube ganz
ehrlich dass das sehr sehr schwer sein
wird wenn charts die dinge die ihm am
herzen liegen
weiter als monarch so deutlich macht
klima ist eine ausnahme klima ist
heutzutage mainstream aber zum beispiel
seine kritik die es detail gingen an
bestimmten städtebauliche sachen
hat er hat alle geschrieben er hat
zettel geschrieben und das wird er
künftig nicht mehr so können kleine die
institution
dort also durchaus zu gefährden er hat
nun und jetzt sind wir schon wieder bei
der wirtschaft frau von brede und sie
haben das im grunde genommen auch in den
kontext gesetzt zur zustimmung auch zum
königshaus wir haben aktuell wirklich
ein krisenhafte großbritannien was
wirtschaft angeht aber auch
institutionen also ein paar welle davon
haben wir die luft geworfen schon den
drechselt auf jeden fall die
schottischen bestrebungen auf
unabhängigkeit die ja nur auf eis gelegt
sind
frau station ist glaube ich wild
entschlossen da noch einmal weiter zu
drehen das rad die inflation jetzt im
zweistelligen bereich
das sind ja auch sachen da kann er nicht
einfach eingreifen aber trotzdem wird er
doch eine verantwortung dafür spüren ja
eine große verantwortung also das größte
glaube ich bremse problem im moment ist
wirklich die inflation und die und die
energiepreise also auch nicht unähnlich
was hier in deutschland und auf dem
kontinent generell das ist einfach was
die leute weil sie direkt betrifft nicht
und da ist es nun besonders wichtig dass
man eine figur hat der mann vertraut die
ein bisschen wenn man will sogar
aufheitert oder irgendwie zuversicht
bringt weil im moment ist ja nicht so
dass ein sehr unsichere zeiten es gibt
ein krieg in europa die leute haben
angst und sie und es wird jetzt kälter
werden nicht alles diese sachen und da
ist es besonders wichtig dass man sich
eben nicht verliert in irgendwelchen was
der prinz hat ja auch diese tendenz ist
ein bisschen in kleinen diskussion zu
verlieren und detail mit da muss er
schon so ein bisschen eine sich ändern
oder oder sich anpassen an diese neue
sehr viel größere rolle das was toni
passen sagt dass er menschlich ist das
das ist sympathisch nicht
aber das hat natürlich macht ihn auch
sehr viel verletzlicher als die könig
nicht und wie sie katastrophale ehe das
hat ihm dann auch das haben die leute
dann übelgenommen jedenfalls teilweise
also es ist sehr viel komplexer und
schwieriger es ist wenn man will klarer
und einfacher wenn man sich wenn man
über dem ganzen schwebt und eben keine
emotionen zeigt das tut er nicht mehr in
der tat und tony paterson auch sie als
sozusagen der charts fan aber durchaus
auch der kritiker auch der aktuellen
situation
es gibt viele die sich jetzt noch mal zu
wort gemeldet haben auch zum zustand
großbritanniens zum beispiel laut peter
mennel sondern frühere eu-kommissar und
auch mit vielen verwendung
großbritannien der jetzt von einer ära
des niedergangs spricht für
großbritannien
die frage ist also kann charles mit dem
was er ja an langer erfahrung mitbringt
das königreich zusammenhalten ich denke
nur bedingt ich meine das ist wird auch
politisch hauptsächlich politisch
entschieden was alle alarmierend ist
dass laut umfragen also 69 prozent der
briten glauben dass es bergab geht in
großbritannien das ist eine enorme
prozentuell tut dass ich das ja auch
aber die haben die erwartung dass es
auch nicht aufhört ja natürlich daran
aber ich meine das ist wenn man von
diesem gestartet es ist nicht besonders
freudig
es ist natürlich die politische lage und
großbritannien hat jetzt neuen premier
ministerium und die wurde beschrieben
als sein
schlechtes nachahmung von
der vorgänger schlechte kopie von
münster churchill war
und sie ist dort mit einem hauchdünnen
mehrheit aus der eigenen partei und der
fraktion stellt die frage ist und mehr
leute sind für labour für die opposition
heute als den konservativen
das heißt in den nächsten zwölf monaten
oder vielleicht 18 monaten wird
höchstwahrscheinlich
neuwahlen geben und mit einer labour
geführten regierung also wie das
aussehen wird ist es aber zumindest
werden die briten dann politisch eine
entscheidung getroffen haben und das vom
kann man anfangen sache besser zu das
ist jetzt hier eine ziemlich deutliche
aussage weil ihr datum wenn wir das
jetzt nach was sehen wäre deutlich vor
dem eigentlich angestrebten wahldatum
sie sind ganz sicher dass das virus
heutige neuwahl haben also ich bin
ziemlich sicher dass so was sie hat ein
vielleicht ein jahr zeit und was gutes
einfach in standby auch boris ist
natürlich wird ihr leben sehr schwer
machen
hat er schon mich er hat mir dann nach
dem tod der queen hat er ja dann auch
noch mal geredet im unterhaus um zu
zeigen dass er es besser kann eigentlich
was er ist also ein guter redner wenn
und da hat es sich auch schon vorher
geschrieben und vorbereitet nicht und er
wird dass ihr weiterhin das leben schwer
machen und zeigen dass er eigentlich
obwohl sie einen wenn man noch mal die
abläufe dieses tages dieses donnerstages
sich durch vor augen denn sie hat ja
einen vorlauf gehabt von ungefähr zwei
stunden damit sie auch ihre
protokollarisch hatte sie ja die erste
pflicht sozusagen der ersten reaktion
aber wenn ja sehr gern
einen wurf machen es ist alles furchtbar
ich habe in london in der zweiten hälfte
der 70er jahre gelebt in dem winter auf
des content wo jeden nachmittag das
nicht ausgeschaltet wurde sowohl sechs
wochen lang in london der männlich
abgeholt wurden die leichen nicht
beerdigt werden konnten also es war so
die yorkshire meiners haben dass man zum
stillstand gebracht man dachte schlimmer
kann es nicht werden also wenn ich das
damals mit heute vergleichen würde ich
sagen da ist heute geht es noch
einigermaßen damals hat es zu dem
radikalen
regierungswechsel wird mehr
gesellschaften haben und ich kann sie
erinnern helmut schmidt auch die frage
damals braucht deutschland eine maggie
thatcher hatte geantwortet nein
deutschland braucht eine absage der
schmerz muss erst mal so groß sein damit
man reform machen kann und vielleicht
sind wir so was auch in zukunft gut aus
[Musik]
das forum wird genau herr killinger als
sie müssen im grunde genommen man könnte
ja sagen die reformen könnten im
königshaus beginnen das wäre ja eine der
aufgaben von charles die angehen möchte
sehen sie nicht so es heißt ja etwas
lang ein bisschen anderem ein naja
natürlich muss sich anpassen er muss
modernisieren das kit gewillt kultur ist
ganz wichtig was seine platten sagte
kann ich nur voll unterschreiben aber
gerade wenn man sich den trostlosen
zustand der britischen politik moment
anschaut glaubt man im ernst dies der
zeitpunkt wo die briten die monarchie
aufgeben würden was ist denn die
alternative eine von diesen
zwiespältigen figuren die nur widerstand
und und gewinn und widerstand auf allen
seiten erzeugen hat man sich mit der
massiven so will ein stück stabilität in
einer zeit wo alle institutionen in
gefahr sind zu bröckeln und einzustürzen
ich glaube nicht deshalb dass hier der
zeitpunkt ist gerade im zustand eines
welches momentan jetzt welches wirklich
da niederlegt danach rufen die monarchie
sozusagen abzuschaffen sie muss sich
organisieren absolut aber ich glaube sie
ist ein kontrastmittel zu den übrigen
welt die vor lauter unwissenheit über
die zukunft und niedergeschlagenheit
nicht weiß wo die reise geht man hat
wenigstens eine institution die seit
1000 jahren stabil ist ich meine das
doch nicht schlecht ist doch nun ein
ausweis von und zuversicht glaube ihre
handlanger linie wir nehmen das hier mit
rein und nicht versucht frau von treten
jetzt doch noch mal hier denn den roten
teppich zu rollen nicht um frau trust zu
verteidigen ich glaube dass wir jetzt so
viel verlangt aber
um noch einmal auf den punkt zu kommen
was star gemacht hat und was wir alle
auch mit interesse beobachtet ihrer
seinen ersten auftritt vor ein paar
tagen in westminster hall vor beiden
kammern des parlaments ihre hausaufgaben
in house of lords dass er gesagt hat das
parlament ist das herz auch unsere
demokratie ja dass im grunde genommen
auch so mal eine hand reichen zu sagen
freunde wir gehen das zusammenhang jetzt
bewusstsein bestimmt also in dieser
rolle bewusst aber er weiß auch dass er
keine politische rolle spielen darf
nicht und um liszt rus zu beschreiben
also sie enden ein schwacher abklatsch
von mister ihre ihre politiken ihre
policen sind ähnlich also sind sie sehr
vielen free market und so weiter aber
sie hat mich die personen die
persönlichkeit von frauchen und sie hat
auch nicht die ideologie weil sie war ja
eigentlich zum beispiel für dafür in der
europäischen union zu bleiben und hat
dann ihre meinung geändert also sie er
sie ist ein magister hatte super grund
überzeugen wie hätte sie nie geändert so
ist dem ist das nicht die
leute ein bisschen so wie der wind geht
das wird schauen müssen wir schauen ob
das eine überlebensfähige strategie ist
aber ich möchte doch noch mal jetzt
kommen auf die den fast den zwang wenn
man wandel angeht und ich gucke jetzt
noch mal toni per tastendruck thomas
kielinger also die zwänge des wandels
sagen dass ich der begriff der firma ist
gefallen dass ich die firma die ja
einiges kostet den britischen
steuerzahler so schlankmacher beginnen
so schlank mache dass es akzeptabel ist
dass ich vielleicht aus buckingham
palace zum teil einen öffentlichen raum
mache dass ich klar ins haus was die
mitarbeiter angeht verschlanke sind dass
bestrebungen
irgendwoher halt nichts man sollte aber
nichts angefangen
hat schon damit angefangen haben sagt
der gesamt personal gefeuert hat von
clarence house
während diese bewegung
habe ich denke schon das war ein
fehler aber ich denke schon dass er die
eine verschlankung durchführen wird im
königshaus es ist und grüne über den
zweiten das war die firma und jeder
müsste eine bestimmte rolle spielen und
das wird er nicht hat schon gesagt dass
er diesen das nicht haben möchte es ist
jetzt reduziert auf die werden jetzt im
eigenen leben genannt also die engsten
kreise seiner familie
und die sollen jetzt regie führen und
nicht viel mehr man muss aber auch sagen
gekostet fehlt die monarchie aber sie
bringt auch viel
diese ja
natürlich auch die ganze volk junge
hilft dem tourismus so dass ich sage ja
unter kieninger weil sie sich auch grad
noch mal einbringen das ist jetzt 79
jahre alt
er hat in diesen ersten reden immer
etwas von der endlichkeit von einer
mission gesprochen
wird er sowas sein wie ein übergangs
könig der sehr früh also die die
verleihung des prince of wales an an
seinen ältesten sohn ist ja ganz schnell
erfolgt ist das ein beleg dafür dass er
sofort mit rein soll ins team
ja da ist er schon er gehört ja zum kern
zur kernmannschaft wie
geschildert hat übergangs könig mit dem
wort bin ich etwas vorsichtig erst mal
weil wir gar nicht wissen ob das hohe
alter welches in der königsfamilie
braucht ist offenbar auch auf ihn
übergeht und der vielleicht zwanzig
jahre lang auf der bühne stehen wird und
zweitens wie wir vorhin diskutierten hat
er mit der umweltfrage ein thema der
gegenwart
erwischt wenn man so will welches ihnen
sehr weit tragen wird im dialog der
gesellschaft die gesellschaft 40 durch
diesen könig sozusagen gespiegelt finden
mit den themen es sozusagen moderne
angetreten dann hat er etwas dazu
schokolade ist etwas großväterlichen er
hat eine stimme die ist ein wunderbarer
bariton wenn sie ist unterscheidet sich
von den königen die steif und
zurückhaltend waren er ist glaube ich
mehr als darüber einig er ist eine neue
ära er ist eine neue ära und wie lange
dauert das wissen wir nicht aber ich
glaube dass sie nicht sehr kurz sein
wird
da gehen wir sozusagen miteinander und
fragt bredow wenn sie mögen eröffnen sie
unsere schlussrunde grundsätzlich sind
diese wechsel ja ein heikler moment dass
in dem fall für die krone es gibt kein
vakuum letzte atemzug
königin des tot es lebe der könig da
gibt es kein problem aber es gibt die
frage der akzeptanz also welchen sinn
macht die monarchie noch also war es
wert wie wir das jetzt auch gesagt haben
die monarchie macht für die briten noch
sehr viel sinn die ist eben doch gelebt
respektiert und von der mehrheit der
bevölkerung unterstützt sichern gibt es
kritiker halten das ich glaube dass
charles vor hat lange zu dienen und das
hat er auch in seinen reden jedenfalls
so angedeutet dass er vielleicht sogar
ähnlich wie seine mutter bis zu sein ist
das gleiche genau und dann das heißt das
könnte könnte eben noch 20 jahre sein
dann wird wohl leben natürlich auch was
und das hat er aber auch selber gewusst
und also ich sehe dass am fluss ich
positiv als ich glaube dass wenn es so
weiter geht oder wenn man wenn er seine
sache so wie man denkt gut machen wird
glaube ich dass sie auch in 20 jahren
die monarchie noch das anders
wäre das auch ihre perspektive toni
petterson dass wir sagen viel groß bist
du ich hoffe dass eigentlich habe ich
mache mir große sorgen wenn ich diese
meinungsumfragen lese zb 18 bis 30
jährige nur 30 prozent
denken dass die monarchie ja sofort
stehen sollen in seiner jetzigen form
und leute die interviews sind also auch
im britischen fernsehen an der
bushaltestelle zum beispiel ich sagen
wir dann für das was haben die für uns
getan es gibt man muss war man also
diese diese beerdigung anschaut und sind
strömen viele viele leute nach
westminster euro
darf man nicht davon ausgehen dass die
mehrheit der briten irgendwie absolut
teuer königs anhänger sind sind sie
nicht viele leute denken überhaupt nicht
drüber nach und viele von ihnen lehnen
diese sache ab kann die monarchie herr
matussek die klammer bleiben für diese
gesellschaft nach ihrer erfahrung war
meine erfahrung ist hier nur bedingt
gültig ich glaube nach dem was hier
gesagt ich glaube dass das richtig ist
die chance ist da aber wir machen die
rechnung ohne den wirt und der wird sind
unsere gesellschaften die sich im
augenblick rasant ändern durch die
globalisierung durch die neuen medien
durch so viele dinge und da weiß ich
nicht ob die monarchie sozusagen das
bindemittel auch in zukunft sein würden
ich hoffe ich hoffe es ich hoffe auch
dass die chance hat aber ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich bin dann mit prognosen
ein bisschen vorsichtig danke herr
matussek
henninger sie hatten das erste und sie
bekommen auch das letzte wort in der
sendung ganz konzentriert ist also
überleben der monarchie aus ihrer
perspektive
ja ich glaube sie hat eine große chance
auch weil ringsum so viele säulen der
beständigkeit dabei sind zu bröckeln
sehen sie die zustimmung zur politik
unter den menschen in den westlichen
gesellschaften wie sie gefallen man hat
keine zuversicht mehr in den der
fähigkeit der politik die dinge in der
hand zu behalten und die zukunft zu
steuern und zu regieren wir leben im
zeitalter höchster ungewissheit
dramatische
abkehr von allen gewissheiten die wir
noch in der zeit des kalten krieges
hatten und in dieser zeit glaube ich
kommt auf die monarchie eine ganz
besondere aufgabe zu geraten auch eine
mission
darzustellen das sind doch stabile
institutionen geben kann und viel glück
für charles wenn ihr das gelingt er wird
es abhängen davon wie er selber mit dem
gefühls kultur das land umgeht wie er
selber seinen mund halten kann wenn es
nicht tun lich ist offen zu reden aber
ich glaube die monat ihre chance in der
zeit der abbrüche der wir leben der
ungewissheiten die zukunft noch ein
bisschen mehr dauer und kontinuität
darzustellen dafür den menschen auch
zufällig zugegen weiterhin ein anker
seine was jetzt gerade nicht hören
konnten die runde hat gesagt viel glück
das wird er brauchen sagt thomas
matussek ich darf nicht ganz herzlich
bedanken
frau von bredow die herren für diese
runde mit diesen verschiedenen aspekten
und blickwinkeln die sie uns gegeben
haben meine damen und herren und auch
vielen dank dass sie ihre zeit mit uns
geteilt haben und das letzte wort das
gehört sich so hat die queen elizabeth
die zweite von ihr ist folgendes zitat
überliefert wir sollten uns nicht zu
ernst nehmen hat sie gesagt keiner von
uns hat ein monopol auf die weisheit ich
danke ihnen und wünsche gute information
bei phoenix
und direkt nach uns info nächster tag
mit maria weber sehr empfohlen
[Musik]